[ __ ] la bella a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo modo io son of a
bitch
io sono un africa [ __ ] gente sono free
che jay e lui è il budello shop now
la panza de fori sto pulendo lo sa solo
lui comunque tratto c'è la scopa dentro
il pavimento bellissimo comunque ragazzi
sono rimasti che avevo fatto questa
credo contento che ci sono tutte queste
stanze belle da fare facciamola 102 otto
ragazzi nell'ultimo episodio beccato
popolar location vecchia quella della
scuola che è stata proprio che è stata
proprio una cosa bella voce anno questo
è il pezzo dove erano fuori alito
pesante usa listerine chi è che ha fatto
sto verso bruttissimo orribile ancora
stia chi ha già dall'ultima puntata
rapino di aghi perché ci sono gli aghi
torna sono faringei eri tu che aiutano
era lui che ha lottato prima via via via
via via via via via via via via via più
veloce
porca [ __ ] non suicida entrare lo fate
un cavallo che è successo ma dove c'è un
cavallo gigante che ingloba in check in
o cavalli
oddio dove quando carica non lo vedo è
un problema questo mi fate entrare da
qualche parte per l'amor di dio o sono
entrato giorno c'è un bambino a casa
io sento il cavallo che si muovevano non
lo vedo fantastico vero zio che noi
siamo forti vieni a stringermi la mano
[Musica]
hai trovato un pezzo di carta facile
capire che cosa rappresenta questo pezzo
di fotografia non è che me ne freghi
molto con un cavallo titano che corre
non ho ben capito che cosa ma sbloccato
il bambino che mi ha detto trova la cosa
che chi devo trovare devo trovare un
cavallo l'ho trovato il cavallo ammessa
me besame mucho di qua recano in filo
calandra [ __ ] laida senti ma quant
si bella o come lo piglia al culetto
nella sede hanno capito cosa devo fare
fotografarti a queste foto vanno a
finire tutte quante su
www.bookingshow.com o no perché non ho
capito il senso di ricordato quanto la
presa nel deretano
è la madonna quanti sono oddio ci sono
duemila cavalli no seriamente qua dentro
non mi prendono sono dentro la tana il
pausa pugno ma sono dentro ma che vuoi o
non ci si rieduca che successo spirit be
nice
è quindi ho vinto dai toni va vj signori
fa vj quello che finisce con la effe
finisce con j in questo caso [ __ ] j però
ho fatto l'accento due ragazzi dovevo
fotografare un cavallo c'è ditemi voi se
è normale me lo dici tu sei normale il
suo valore che a soli facciamola ha
visto che era accorto questo che
facciamo 100 108 dai l'ultima quella che
dovrebbe in teoria essere l'ultima chi
ci sono livelli che non durano una mazza
ma ditelo cioè io pensavo durassero una
vita e mezza sena dunque tragédie la
parola tragédie mi sa di bello mi sa
proprio di parti hard restare a casa
quelle norme che abbiamo visto
nell'ultimo episodio di tre doubt
c'è un po di morro e di el'ati bella
prova che tranquilla zia che sulle
supposte con si apre l'era portata non
si apre la porta bella lite in questo
caso sono anche contento che non si apra
la porta meglio così guarda non ho ben
capito cosa devo fare in questa stanza
però vabbè ma doc e bel quadro
mi vedo vecchia allo specchio però quale
gli specchi sono rotti a 2 miliardi di
anni di sfiga tutti a voi
andiamocene di qualche veramente rocca e
raccapricciante come posto c'è il piano
di sotto grazie a dio dato c'è una roba
illuminata lì quindi la devo prendere
per forza il grammofono a il grammofono
mancano delle parti
il cazzo reed i ragazzi di vista
angosciando dove diavolo è stati pack up
che ha riso in questo momento chi è
stato a ri salverà dal meno male che al
computer grazie a dio mi fai lo gare su
facebook
sai montando il video di dredd out che
bello sempre sempre un lavoro che su you
tube fame non bella tutti ragazzi forza
preti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video no è immesso nella stessa
posizione in cui sono messo lì adesso è
raccapricciante avessi e crepa tanto con
i fazzoletti qua è una cosa molto ma
molto singolare zio non posso dire addio
steve jobs book ambìto karanja makan
duren quei ragazzi fa parte apple in
generale cesto telefono pajun iris rom
boicottiamo apple e samsung smt
compriamo tutti i ris phone che non so
che che minchia sia fatto da uno steve
jobs nato in thailandia
oddio chiusa per tutto
tornò suonare devo fare suprema e non
avrà anche visto cosa ho preso non l'ho
visto cosa ho preso adesso non posso
andare avanti faccio una protesta questo
fare è preso un pezzo del grammofono per
forza a ecco il grammofono player is
missing world park checa che ne so io
non so dove sto andando ma la musica
stadi vede ancorato a [ __ ] il rombo
pagatissimo ma che che il sonno la serie
una bambina morta ma che morisse il
cugino di terzo grado vabbè dai aree
orgasmi sono preso ma di un male che non
avete idee vanno a tocco l'aveva schifo
lì si propri devi fare una vita e zia
aceto dico basta che palle legami serve
un altro pezzo del grammofono che non ho
capito dove dovrebbe essere all
ma dov'è
sento gente che anzi ma non ho capito
chi
la madonna mi son gas mando nell'anima
proprio ma dov'è adesso non la prima
corsa non mi enormi nota la zia bella le
deve [ __ ] va si no
oddio che capelli e meglio loro cosa ha
offerto io non ho capito questa due
siamo dio ma quando mai
ok hobbit e oggetti cartelli della
minkia chi è che fa che cosa
spero stai calmo ho detto e la madonna
sono morto bellissimo non ho complimenti
un livello semplice e crimini vado mi
son passato che non ho capito di qua va
bene di qua va bene ok quando sento il
rumore di qualcuno che sta per saltargli
in faccia tipo adesso ho trovato la foto
completa della figura a livella una
bambina con la sua bambola la bambola
era quella che mi seguiva prima o
contento e ha trovato tutti i pezzi lo
schifo non ho capito perché mi è saltato
alla gola un tizio prima sta cosa qua mi
è sfuggita è nel proprio sfuggita sta
cosa
ok di qua non ci devo andare ho già
capito non sono proprio sicurissimo che
vada bene di qua però ci andiamo lo
stesso chitarra sta succedendo qualcosa
da fermi cos'è sto rumore è che ora è
solo uno degli episodi che sono sono un
asso nel concludere così gli episodi che
lega spero che visto vi sia piaciuto
come al solito mi è piaciuta
sull'argomento e non mi piace anche a
pagine di facebook che conta iscrizione
sensi di schede il cb diavolo prossimo
vito e loria